all right lisa vanderpump dogs
has arrived welcome to founder pump dogs
i feel like people are going to be
surprised by this show
because they are going to think it's
vanderpump rules
in a rescue center and it is not that
no not at all wow did you think that
i thought it was gonna go one of two
ways either that or what it is which is
kind of like house hunters for dogs
this was such a feel-good show you could
just watch it on an endless loop
oh gosh you're right no no no no it's
not at all like kind of purples
this is a passion project and this
is about you know finding the perfect
home because a lot of these dogs
have very sad stories and they come to
us and this is their second chance
no no there can't be any emotional
dysfunction
in rescue it's hard enough and
emotionally challenging
enough as it is now if i had staff
in sir that was like diligent and
getting the crispy
chicken to the table as they were
getting the dogs to write home
it would be much easier it would be so
much easier yeah you wouldn't have that
other show then
if everything was running that smoothly
over there
it'd be a beautiful thing maybe nobody
watched but i'd love it
this is her me mary it's like a dating
process
this is larry you want to have a little
foreplay before you go all the way
what was your favorite part of making
vanderpump dogs because you're really
involved you are the person connecting
everyone who comes into the rescue at
least
the ones that are featured on the show
with their perfect pet
i have an incredible staff at vanderpump
dogs
make no mistake about it and some of
our favorite moments i think's just been
the stories
of the people and it's like who's
rescuing who
i'm just so happy that he's going to be
my forever dog
i couldn't have asked for anything
better we've rescued out two and a half
thousand
dogs now or nearly that domestically
and you know finding happy homes and
you'll see
some of the stories some of the dogs
have sad situations but
the show's got real feel good factor a
lot of poignancy
heartbreak of some of the stories we've
heard before they get to us
and then the rehabilitation i tore
through all the
screeners i was like i got through all
six that were out there and i was like i
need
more of this show it's like that
it's that enjoyable to watch and i think
it also helps to kind of
course correct a little bit she's with
us again the last time we saw the rescue
center on they show
the lucy lucy of it all that you can see
that it's more than just
that scandal what you do there well that
was one
one of the things that we really do try
to do is you know
stop dogs from ending up in shelters you
know so that whole situation
was unfortunate um but yes it's got a
real feel good factor but i just want to
thank my staff
all of them they've been incredible for
the love of dog there's a few of them
that didn't want to be on camera
but they're just all amazing they really
are they've done a wonderful job
through the whole 14 months of cobit
what do you have to say to those ladies
on that show you used to be on who say
they deserve
a check for this show making it to air
because of the lucy lucy
uh story that happened on your last
season on housewives
well does everybody do they deserve a
check for over served as well because
that was at my house what's that got to
do with anything you know
um i don't know who says that but you
know
i have fond memories of uh beverly hills
housewives
my favorite tagline was i'm passionate
about dogs i'm passionate about dogs
just not crazy about [ __ ] what do you
hope the viewers take away from watching
this show that's all about
dogs not [ __ ] well i think it's the
importance of rescue
and the importance of you know our fight
against yulin and ending the inhumane
treatment of dogs and just to be aware
of being
being kind to our furry friends i think
people will love the show like you
but wow yeah they could really have one
every week you could have one every week
so the feel good factor is overwhelming
this show is hitting peacock
just as you're getting back to work on
your other show vanderpump rules
oh we're already way in the middle of
that how's it going so far
i'm very people are hungry for that lisa
you know they want it back
well we will not disappoint because
we're already a third of the way in
and out telling you it's you can tell
they've been locked up for a year that's
for sure
everybody's got a point of view and
they're willing to air it invent it
we've got a couple of new people uh
we've lost a couple of people
along the way but we still got a big
cast of people that are very familiar
with each other sometimes a little too
familiar
but it's uh it's got a lot of great
energy behind it
and i'm surprised actually i thought
it'd be a slower start but it's not
it's straight out the gate i talked to
tom and ariana i think a day or two
before they were really going
into filming and they're like we are
ready to party let's rip the band-aids
off let's go for it
and james and raquel are engaged these
kids are all growing up i know
i know well yeah james sometimes
there's sometimes he's a little more
complicated and i have to manage him a
little bit more as you will see
um but congratulations stem she's the
best thing that ever happened to him
but you really do see raquel kind of
blossoming blooming this season you
really do
you see her really have a voice she was
very much like a deer caught in the
headlight
you know before but now she's like
actually kind of really comes out of a
shell so it's good to see
yeah i mean lala famously called her
oh god yeah well they've all got a lot
to say that's for sure
but i think it's more mature the show
there are people that really like to
have their opinion
and that's not going to change and
they've certainly got a lot of them
so it's pretty convoluted i'm surprised
actually
how amazingly quick fast-paced and
intense
we're in and we're only a third of the
way through so it's good
yeah think of all the life that happened
in the in-between they got they all
have a lot to share a lot to say and you
said there's some rice
as well a lot of stuff was festering
where they say okay now i want to talk
to you about what
you said on that you know so there was a
lot of that but
you know what give me anything but don't
give me boring you know
you said there's a couple new people but
it seems like the focus is a little more
pared down the last season it was quite
quite the uh giant cast yes it was
yeah you're gonna see it's a little more
focused some people
have a few more challenges that's for
sure but you'll see
you'll be invested in this one this one
will not disappoint you
it's the same van and pump rules any
different but i think you're gonna love
it
that's what i wanna hear all right i
gotta wrap things up here i have one
more
naughty question for you lisa as you you
like to call them
you cleaned up the whole sending the
bill over to kyle thing
on heather de bros podcast we i was at
dinner
with one of our producers and um
she sent a bill over and it wasn't paid
you know
i guess after they let her know it
wasn't paid and then she paid i mean
i wouldn't doubt that she would pay
eventually but she did leave and one of
the bill played
i've used shenanigans in restaurant you
know but i'm also savvy enough to know
that you know he might say no i wouldn't
i sent it to him but i gave the
waitress an imprint of my card so that i
said if he says no
run my card and i just said but
and she came out of a restaurant saying
yes i'm nice she dined and dashed well
that's not true so you know i have to
kind of end it there and then you know
kyle and teddy are still
upset about you crossing out faces and
drawing on the photo outside the
restaurant
there's a man outside always waits for
you know people to sign photos so he had
a picture of the cast
and asked lisa to sign it because he had
already had lisa rena's signature on it
and she
put x's through our faces and mustache
on lisa running me which i know some
people would say oh that's so funny
but he she ruined the photo for this guy
yeah he could have gotten
everybody's photo and excited about it
but she had to go through and
you know but i got three exes
i'm the only one that got three x's
right and i got mustaches but rena
already had her signature there
the thing that's bizarre to me is like
if she's going to go about this like
she's so unbothered she doesn't want to
do this why is she going
out of her way to consistently try to do
things to shape i mean she's gone on
multiple
podcasts that talk badly about me if you
really are moving on
move on what's your response to that
well okay a paparazzi guy
again kyle makes it about her and says
it was a kid's picture
it was a paparazzi guys you know when
they have the 10 by 12
he said will you sign this for me so i
said yeah and i thought well i'll also
draw a little moustache on kyle
and then i thought okay and he was
loving it and so excited but kyle
started saying it was a kid's photograph
it's the paparazzi guy that stands
outside
shoe dark head guy very sweet guy and
beverly glenn
is probably gonna sell that picture for
a fortune as
they always do it wasn't a kid's picture
they don't walk around kids with ten by
twelves
of housewives just another attempt to
try to malign me
like she said i dined and dashed that's
why i had to show the
receipts of my bank account now there
you have it
why did teddy deserve three x's though
everyone else got one squiggle and she
her whole body got crossed out
oh well you know i think you know the
answer to that
miss in avoidability what about that one
that might be better
uh one word to describe vanderpump dogs
one reason to tune in
[Music]
i'd say poignancy i would say passion
and poignancy
mix those together and you see the love
and you see the heart warming
beautiful beautiful show i'm very proud
of it actually and thank you for saying
you watched all of it at once because i
think a lot of people are gonna do that
yeah i just i know it's a beautiful show
so thanks bryce good to see you darling
good to see you congratulations on the
show it is so good
it may be i already have two rescue dogs
and i was like do i need to go get
another one
all right well call me if you do big
kisses we'll deal
bye